the jogan experience I I got sued I mean
it's it's like it's why I have eno
Insurance because I got [__] sued for
half a million uh it was that it was
that [__] uh for defamation because I
[__] on that lawyer on the air when he
called in he was like the guy's right
activist and he called up and uh I
insulted him for an hour and I imped
that he [__] chickens like it was
funny um and he I I remember saying like
he he sued me for defamation and I
remember saying this guy wants to kill
me but he can't so he's getting me
legally cuz we met once I he thought I
wanted to settle with him because he
amended his complaint he said that I was
having people send him Anthrax or or
white powder implying it was Anthrax it
was [__] crazy so I had to meet in my
lawyer's office just to tell him like
dude I like that's insane I thought like
as two people right but he thought I was
going to settle so we shook hands and
met and he was just like a little fishy
weird guy um and then he just continued
to sue me and it finally went away I had
a great lawyer and in court 8 months
later or n9ine months later um the judge
didn't like him and my attorney started
reading things I said to him on the air
and all the other lawyers in the court
started laughing and all those people
laughing at him um got him to go oh
you're honor we can settle this so they
went in the back and that was it no
money was paid it was just dropped oh he
just didn't want to be mocked and that
he didn't want to be mocked and he wrote
like this Manifesto and he mentioned me
in it um and that guy over the [__]
pandemic
uh dressed up like a Fed Ex worker and
went to a judge's house and shot her son
and killed him that was the guy that's
the same guy Roy Roy and Hollander and
he that was the guy that sued that's the
guy that sued me holy [__] and he went
to uh he was going to I think murder
Sonia soraa I think her name is the
Supreme Court Justice and they said he
might have killed somebody else in La
they don't know but yeah he was going to
uh shoot her and her son answered the
door holy [__] D yeah but I knew that
guy
it was more than a lawsuit because he
had challenged me to a duel I didn't
tell he CH on the air he goes you want
to go to South America and have a duel
like it was really bizarre that he chose
one those 10 Paces things yes like it
was so nuts Who Um and then he started
wanting to come back in studio and fight
us he's like it'll just be me against
the three hosts fighting all these crazy
messages oh my god um but I knew I can't
believe that was the guy I never knew
that that's the guy yeah so that like
when that type of [__] happens it it's
like it does change you a little bit
you're like wow that guy was right that
guy literally wanted to murder me it
wasn't me being crazy or paranoid um and
most people from what I heard he had
cancer like they said he had like uh
incurable stage four cancer and then he
wound up doing that and then he just
blew his brains out shot himself oh wow
yeah so they never got him he he did it
to himself he killed himself yeah I
think the cops were coming to get him
and he and he uh he killed himself so
yeah that could have been a lot worse um
boy and I and I look back on that and I
also feel good about myself like hey you
read this guy right like I read what
type of person he was like you know is
you get pretty good instincts like if
somebody's heckling you you understand
is this guy having fun or is this guy
trying to be a piece of [__] cuz he
resents me you you learn pretty quickly
to read motives yeah um and I just it
was just maybe it's just an animal gut
instinct but I'm like this guy's a
[__] problem um so yeah I got very
lucky with that that we we never uh it
never got to that I wonder how much you
having him humiliated ramped up all of
his anger it led to him murdering people
you know I I don't know because it was
years later and it was also he had this
thing with women like I originally going
to we were going to interview him
because he was suing Colombia because of
their guys studies or or women's studies
sorry and so I was like look I don't
like anything that's Progressive and
Exclusive by Nature like you know what I
mean like hey how come they're not doing
guys so I'm like let's see what but then
it became apparent he just sues women so
then we started to make fun of him um
because it's like I it wasn't the
principle of Colombia doing this it was
like you just have a [__] heart on
and want to sue women so then we kind of
made fun of them um and it got ugly and
I was just being a dick like I was on
the air um and that's what really SP I
don't think that I think he had so many
of these problems and it was much more
about women than anything I said to him
like my humiliation of him was years
earlier but I do think I humiliated him
and he really wanted to cuz my attorney
at the time uh his name was Tom Ferber
he was a great lawyer and he they my Law
Firm hated him so much they
retroactively knocked down what they
were charging me they go this guy's such
a bad guy that we're going to charge you
less and we're going to make it
retroactive like they were so offended
by what he was doing as an attorney wow
so I I I got lucky with really good
people and they really took good care of
me you also got lucky that you caught
him before the cancer yes 100% 100%
because again do I think he would have
hunted me down and K no I I I think the
judge for him was a bigger one but I
mean I'm sure it would have felt good
for him if he could have um especially
he was on a run so let me stop by the
radio station yeah and oddly enough it
happened in the town I grew up in which
is again a pure coincidence but happened
in North Brunswick um he went to kill
her and just unfortunately her son
answered the dooro boy yeah you get like
I've gotten so many threats um over the
years like and like legit you know radio
podcasting you don't see who it's not
like live standup like there's a lot of
people that you don't see um and I used
to answer them I have I have hundreds of
[__] hate mail messages and I used to
go back and forth with people um and I
eventually stopped because then people
like I had a couple people talking about
you better watch your back or talk about
getting shot and they were using their
real names I'm like all right if this
guy's using his real name he's a [__]
there's something wrong with him right
and I don't know what he looks like and
he knows what I look
like